SETH VARGO: Hi
there, and welcome
to the fifth video in our
series on SRE and DevOps.
My name is Seth, and
I'm a developer advocate
at Google focused on
infrastructure and operations.
LIZ FONG-JONES: And
I'm Liz, an SRE focused
on teaching Google Cloud
customers how to build
and operate reliable services.
SETH VARGO: OK Liz, so
I've defined my SLI and--
what are you wearing?
LIZ FONG-JONES:
What do you mean?
The dress and this flying broom?
It's what we wear in the future.
SETH VARGO: You're
from the future?
LIZ FONG-JONES: Yes.
Just keep going, it'll
all make sense in the end.
SETH VARGO: OK, Liz.
As I was saying, I've
defined my SLIs and my SLOs
and I calculated
my error budgets.
And my teams are working
together instead of fighting,
and I'm done!
I've successfully implemented
DevOps and SRE practices.
LIZ FONG-JONES: But you
have customers, right?
SETH VARGO: I mean, we
tell our investors that.
LIZ FONG-JONES: So if
you have customers,
they might want to connect
their servers to your service.
You have an API, right?
SETH VARGO:
[UNSURE MUMBLING NOISES]
Maybe?
LIZ FONG-JONES:
Well, now you have
to teach your customers
how to do DevOps and SRE.
SETH VARGO: Wait, so you're
saying that all of the stuff
we've talked about in
all of these videos,
I have to go teach
that to my customers?
LIZ FONG-JONES:
Yes, yes, you do.
SETH VARGO: But all of those
things like toil and error
budgets and SLIs and
SLOs-- all of that?
LIZ FONG-JONES: Well, you
technically don't have to,
but have you ever had
a user be angry at you
because your service is down?
Yeah.
Well, what happens if
your service behaves
in a way that's in spec for
your beautifully-crafted SLOs,
but that breaks the
customer expectation?
SETH VARGO: Yeah,
I can see that,
and no one likes unhappy users.
We certainly don't.
LIZ FONG-JONES: And you can
imagine that at Google's scale,
that with that
many unhappy users,
we'd want to do
something about it.
So anytime you have
a consumable service
that has an API,
that's going to happen.
And the best way to make for
your customers to be happy
is to communicate clearly about
how your service is intended
to behave, which
coincidentally means
exposing your SLOs to them.
SETH VARGO: Interesting.
So I have to teach
them how to make
a good SLO for their
systems, and that
will teach them how to interact
correctly with my system?
LIZ FONG-JONES: Exactly.
SETH VARGO: OK, but
I'm not sure I follow.
How is that going to help?
It seems like a lot
of upfront work.
LIZ FONG-JONES: So
once upon a time,
we didn't talk
about SRE publicly.
And we thought of it
as our secret sauce,
and we tried to keep it secret.
And then we learned
a very hard lesson--
our customers had problems,
and they had problems
because they had used
our systems in ways
that we weren't expecting
and that neither of us
were communicating about.
We didn't tell our customers
how our systems were designed,
and they didn't tell us
what they were expecting.
And then when everything
broke, they got very upset,
and you can imagine that
multiplied by millions
or billions of users.
SETH VARGO: Well, I
mean, at Google's scale,
I can imagine how that would
quickly add up over time.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Yep, it sure
did, and we learned eventually
that we can move faster and
ship features to our customers
faster if we're
openly communicating
with our customers and
helping them do SRE.
So the time that we
spend teaching people
about how to do SRE--
why is it paying off a lot?
Because when users apply
these things to their systems,
it makes them have much
less friction with us.
SETH VARGO: I see.
So an initial,
upfront investment
on education around SRE
has long-term dividends?
LIZ FONG-JONES: Exactly.
And it was so
successful that now we
have an entire team,
which is the team that I'm
part of-- the Customer
Reliability Engineering Team,
or CRE.
And CREs are regular Google SREs
that are focused externally.
Instead of working on
our own GCP applications,
we instead help customers
who are implementing
their applications
on GCP, and we
help them also implement SRE
practices like SLIs and SLOs.
And that means that
in the long-term,
we can share information.
We can share our SLOs
with our customers
and have our customers
share their SLOs with us.
So we'll know if we break
one of our customers,
or our customers can figure out
whether an issue they're seeing
is a glitch on their
end or whether it's
something that's in GCP.
SETH VARGO: That's so cool!
Thanks, future Liz!
[SCI-FI TELEPORTATION SOUNDS]
That was weird.
[RUNNING FOOTSTEPS]
[PANTING]
LIZ FONG-JONES: I'm
sorry I'm late, Seth.
Everything OK?
I hope I didn't throw
off the schedule.
SETH VARGO: Not a problem.
We were just talking to a
future version of yourself.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Wait,
a future version of me?
That's so cool!
So you're saying future
me invented a time machine
and then went back in time so
as to make me not late to this?
SETH VARGO: Exactly.
LIZ FONG-JONES:
That's really cool!
What did she say?
SETH VARGO: So we were talking
about the Customer Reliability
Engineering program--
or the CRE program--
here at Google, but I'm
still a little bit unclear
about how it plays into
this bigger DevOps picture.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Ah, yes.
So CRE is Customer
Reliability Engineering,
and we focus on breaking down
the organizational barriers--
not between individual
silos in a single company,
but instead between a Cloud
customer and its platform
provider.
And we also think about,
how do we make failure
a normal, accepted thing?
So for instance, we
make sure that everyone
has service-level
objectives and error
budgets, so we
communicate about what's
an acceptable level
of reliability
so that everyone doesn't
panic when there's
a little bit of downtime.
And also, we focus a
lot on measurement.
So we make sure that everyone
has visibility into the system
so that customers can see how
the platform is performing,
and the platform can see how the
customer service objectives are
faring during an outage.
So in that way, we have a single
pane of glass between everyone.
SETH VARGO: Great.
Thanks, Liz.
And thank you,
everyone, for watching.
Don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
and stay tuned for
future videos--
and maybe a future Liz.
Check out the description
below for more information
about Customer Reliability
Engineering at Google.